a newborn killing nurse a marble-eating
mother and a pop star whose Fame is
thanks to a school shooting you'll never
think of disturbing movies the same way
the 2012 remake of maniac had some
mighty big shoes to fill the 1980
original is one of the most renowned and
reviled slashers of all time it's an
appallingly intimate portrait of a
serial killer who stalks the streets of
New York City in search of vulnerable
women to work his mommy issues out on
Cut to 2012 when the Remake dared to ask
what if this already skin crawling story
was shot almost entirely from the first
person point of view of the killer
working against type Elijah Wood Place
Frank a deeply Disturbed nice guy who
can't be reminded of his lack of a
girlfriend without killing every woman
in the vicinity while Frank makes an
admirable attempt to date normally he
still has a bad habit of draping women's
scalps over vintage mannequins the
result is a film that succeeds in making
Frank pathetic without also making him
Worthy of our pity and in the real world
with the threat of Violence perpetuated
by the rise of insults the horrifying
plausibility of maniac has only become
more and more disturbing all these years
later
2012's excision follows a troubled young
teen and aspiring surgeon named Pauline
as her hormones rage her corporeal
interest proves far more carnal than
clinical obsessed and Outcast Pauline
sinks deeper and deeper into her
blood-soaked Fantasy Life where she Dons
scrubs and bathes in the blood of
patients who are as much her victims as
her lovers wearing its depravity on its
sleeve excision Dives deep into
Unapologetic teenage boundary pushing
with a pitch black wit and a scalpel in
hand
the film has no shortage of Gore but its
true disturbing power lies in its
portrait of a neglected ostracized team
Pauline's steady slip into Destruction
has a clear and preventable trajectory
so it's agonizing to watch the world
fail her at every turn a coming-of-age
horror that fully Embraces all the
bloody realities of morbid teenage angst
excision is a fiendishly offensive
horror comedy about wanting to be loved
and accepted for the little freak you
are can you contract an STD from having
sex with a dead person
on the grounds of a vague religious
disagreement Thomason and her family are
banished from society they build their
cabin on the fringes of Colonial New
England right at the edge of a dark
forbidding Forest one afternoon
Thompson's baby brother vanishes Without
a Trace suspicious of Thomason the
family reasons that the infant was
Spirited Away by a witch with dark
intentions as the days tick by and the
child remains missing a devious
combination of isolation and paranoia
turn thomason's family against her as
they descend into madness it becomes
increasingly difficult to parse the
cabin fever from the Rumblings of an
Ever encroaching force that seems to be
seeping Out of the Woods one of the key
factors in the dread soaked atmosphere
of the witch is its adherence to
historical accuracy making the whole
experience that much more immersive so
when the supernatural begins its
infiltration in the family's Homestead
their struggle with unseen forces begins
to feel very real and threatening
furthermore the film also invites you to
see things from Thompson's perspective
she stands accused of Unthinkable acts
and the self-fulfilling prophecy of the
accusation is truly the stuff of
nightmares
run don't walk as far away as you can
from we are the flesh or if you insist
on toughing it out don't say we didn't
warn you released in 2016 we are the
flesh follows brother sister Duo Lucio
and fauna who are doing their best to
survive in a post-apocalyptic hellscape
they're then shocked when they enter a
decrepit building on the edge of town
and find a man named Mariano ignoring
the fire in his eyes the siblings listen
attentively to Mariano's Devil's deal
food and shelter in exchange for their
help in transforming a building into a
cavernous womb-like Temple to depravity
itself with Lucio and fauna firmly under
his thumb Mariano forces the siblings to
participate in Unthinkable acts of
violence and fleshy transgression the
end result is a combination of sexual
abandon and hallucinatory Terror we are
the flesh is an intense explicit and
Boundary defying descent into madness is
it daring or is it disgusting why not
both seems to be the answer of everyone
involved
It's relatively bloodless compared to
the gorier entries on this list but the
killing of a sacred deer is nevertheless
a deeply unsettling viewing experience
the film is a loose adaptation of one of
the most harrowing chapters in ancient
Greek fiction epigeniah at Alice which
tells of King agamemnon's ritual
sacrifice of his own daughter in
exchange for favorable wins to sail to
Troy directed by Greek filmmaker jorgos
lantimos the film follows Dr Stephen
Murphy a successful heart surgeon who
appears to have it all then one day he
meets a young man named Martin and the
two form a special bond it's only after
Martin inserts himself into the
surgeon's family life that he Reveals
His true intentions he wants Justice
Martin's father died on the operating
table because Dr Murphy was under the
influence by Supernatural means that are
never clearly explained and are all the
more disturbing for it the surgeon's two
children fall ill Dr Murphy is faced
with an impossible decision he must kill
one of his kids or his wife or they will
all perish
[Music]
[Music]
the uncomfortable atmosphere of the
killing of a sacred deer comes from
lantimosas intentionally stilted
Direction This endows everything from
the production design to the visceral
moments of violence with an unnaturally
clinical distance and the creep factor
of Barry keogan's performance is Martin
cannot be overstated from his Candor to
his voracious appetite for spaghetti
everything he does feels slimy and
calculated the thought of innocent lives
being caught on the teeth of life's meat
grinder is inherently upsetting and the
killing of a sacred deer makes an
absolute meal out of it the death of
children is a running theme on this list
and understandably so which is why we've
got this film about a satanic cult
hell-bent on stuffing out as many
innocent lives as possible 2017's
Belgium kicks things off with a
possessed nurse massacring a nursery
full of shrieking newborns and it
doesn't get much better from there the
young age of the film's victims will
obviously be a major turn off to some
viewers but if you can get past the
initial shock of the back-to-back
sadistic set pieces you'll be delighted
to find a sharped edge Supernatural
procedural that pulls no punches few
films are this committed to throwing the
baby out with the bathwater the main
character is Emmanuel Ritter a dedicated
gravel voice detective with the physical
presence of a bull and the Constitution
to match still reeling from the tragic
death of his newborn son detective
Ritter finds himself embroiled in an
investigation into the Catholic
conspiracy responsible for the mass
murder of countless children an ancient
evil is dead headset on clawing its way
back into our world and the question of
whether an emotionally shaken detective
and a would-be priest turned Paranormal
Investigator are the right men for the
job keeps the stakes high and palpable
throughout if you've yet to come across
possum in your movie going Adventures
we're about to ruin your day there are a
number of reasons why this film will get
under your skin the oppressive mood the
enigmatic storytelling and the enormous
human faced spider-legged puppet monster
the plot follows Philip a disgraced
children's Puppeteer who returns to his
hometown after losing his job for an
ominously unrevealed reason while he
attempts to destroy his grotesque
marionette he comes face to face with
his abusive uncle and the dark trauma
that has loomed over him his entire life
possum was written and directed by
Matthew holness whose short story of the
same name was originally published in
the Anthology collection the new uncanny
Tales of unease horror writers were
prompted to use an essential human fear
and Sigmund Freud's essay on The Uncanny
as the jumping off point wholeness
ultimately Drew from not one but two
phobias puppets and doubles considering
that the possum puppet also boasts some
freakishly horrible spider legs we'll go
ahead and unofficially count that as
three phobias the result of this gumbo
of fear is some truly adrenaline pumping
nightmare fuel about a very sad man
trying to destroy something that's as
much a representation of his own trauma
as a reflection of himself the black
long-legged possum man
children run a latent smother any child
without a mother in the year 2000 the
teenage Celeste is a victim of school
shooting somehow despite a serious neck
wound she manages to survive although
the same can't be said for all of her
classmates in the wake of the tragedies
Celeste performs at the memorial service
an original song She Wrote while in the
hospital which then sets her on the path
to international pop stardom voxlux
earns its place on this list thanks to
its alarming and emotionally devastating
depiction of a school shooting
considering the rage-inducing reality of
how frequently such tragedies occur in
the United States the opening scene
feels like a gut punch one where the
effects linger long after the credits
roll that Celeste builds a career off of
that horrific act of violence never sits
quite right and it isn't until the
film's final moments that the uneasy
feeling comes into clearer focus voxlux
is is one of the few films in recent
memory to truly consider the lasting
psychological and cultural aftershocks
of school shootings from the genuine
lasting pain they inflict on survivors
to the commodification of that very pain
many films depict mental institutions as
creepy on the basis that older better
films told us they were creepy but
2018's unsane proves that there's still
plenty of substance to be found by
Shining Light on the institutional
abuses that continue to rage behind
closed doors shot entirely on an iPhone
7 plus unsane breaks from the shuffling
white robed visual language of its
modern peers to underline the very real
fears that still plagued the modern
psychiatric experience the story follows
Sawyer a woman who unknowingly commits
herself to a mental institution during a
routine visit to a therapist trapped in
a situation where she's treated as less
than a person she's horrified to learn
that her old stock works in the hospital
as an orderly but nobody believes that
she has an active restraining order
against this man either that or nobody
cares I'm trying to tell you're not even
listening to me I'm trying to tell you
that the man I'm adding a course of
risperidone and lithium to your meds
one of the more striking entries in
director Stephen soderbergh's ongoing
interest in recession era anxiety unsane
exposes the greedy cost of the American
Health Care system which is Keen to harm
healthy people if it means a profit can
be turned intentionally garish and ugly
to look at this film is an unnerving
viewing experience made all the creepier
by its politically charged approach to
exploitation 2019 swallow follows Haley
Bennett as Hunter a newlywed former
saleswoman who feels increasingly
stifled by her extremely comfortable and
highly controlled domestic life you
might look at Hunter's life and think
she has it all the loving husband the
lavish New York Villa baby on the way so
why is she so sad under the increasingly
crushing pressure of her husband and
in-laws Hunter's deep desire to be
obedient and submissive spills out in
the form of a bizarre Obsession a
compulsive desire to swallow inedible
objects it's the only thing that makes
her feel and troll but his Hunter's
addiction with eating hairpins Marbles
and tacks increasingly puts her unborn
child's viability at risk her Mental
Health crisis reveals her husband's True
Colors easily one of the most
sperm-inducing viewing experiences in
recent memory swallow is a haunting and
isolating film about the domestic
imprisonment and abusive power many
women are forced to endure much of the
film's disturbing power comes from its
sound design which emphasizes the
visceral quality of Hunter's digestive
Rebellion the sound of teeth scraping
across batteries is both unmistakable
and nauseating there are plenty of
movies that are bloodier than swallow
but not many that are more difficult to
sit through
[Music]